[Music]
okay everybody i am absolutely thrilled
today because i am joined by gabriella
pizzolo aka suzy aka suzy poo in
stranger things season four we're gonna
be talking spoilers for season four
volume one so make sure you watch that
first and then come his interview how
you doing today gabby oh i'm good i'm
glad you said spoilers because there's a
whole bunch
oh yeah so we gotta like tiptoe here so
i'm really excited to talk about this
season how great you were in this season
but before we even get into that i just
want to talk about how
your entrance in season three is one of
the most iconic entries for a character
in any tv show and
showing the power of that there's 70
million plays of your version of never
earning story on spotify so has that
been overwhelming for you the positive
response and are you also getting asked
to sing that song a lot now
oh gosh every single time that i go to i
go to comic-cons a lot um and they're so
fun and i usually go with gate in and we
go like as a little pair
um that's the first thing we get asked
to do um we have to have it in the back
of our minds at all times
um
yeah no but it's it's been super fun i
love all the positive response i feel
like that song really like
resurfaced and i grew up an original fan
of neverending stories so like that made
me so happy
um
yeah yeah i think that like honestly the
positive response has been so amazing
and i feel like also like people came up
with like wild theories like i was a
russian
i was a spy at one point like i feel
like it was not just positive response
it was like extreme theorizing like
extreme fixation on the one part like oh
she's gotta be evil there's gotta be
something else and then you see like
she's just a regular kid living in utah
and like she's a hacker so i guess they
were kind of right with like the hacking
but
definitely not for russian you know
espionage just for her own sake
i love you bring that up because you're
you're so right there's so many youtube
videos even if you search now there's
still theories coming out about suzie's
behind it all so
yeah what do you what do you say to the
people though that you also see people
saying oh it's susie's fault hopper got
captured like do you see any of that
angle or you don't see that
um
i mean i definitely could see it i feel
like the show is so
big and so complex that like people find
a way to like trace every single event
back to life
or in moments and it's happened every
single season like i remember
finn got it at one point and like it
just so happened that like
i was one of the people that got it that
season in season three
and
i honestly thought it was really funny
and then i started thinking about it and
i was like
that actually could be true and then i
ended up not being true at all because
the duffers keep their storylines like
so under wraps um for good reason
obviously um
but as soon as i was like reading the
scripts and everything for season four i
was like i hope she's not actually a
spire those people were totally right
and i was like wrong to defend myself
no i love it that's a great answer too
and i like that you're aware of all the
stuff people are saying about susie
that's pretty cool so
was there ever any worry in your head
when season three ended that susie might
just appear in season three and not be
in season four were you kind of given
you know some kind of encouragement that
you're gonna be back
yeah well actually it was like when i
first auditioned i auditioned and it was
like for a one-time appearance and i was
like
okay this is like incredible because i
love this show i love the people on it i
grew up with the kids
in just the entertainment industry and
so i was like
okay this could be a really fun like one
time like chance to get to be on
something so special to them with them
um and then i started hearing you know
oh that she might come back there might
be more
and from that point on once i started
like
actually filming season four i was
thinking like
there's no way that this could have all
started from just like a one-time
appearance they must have known but they
must have just not been saying anything
just so that way like nobody had any
clue because the thing about the show is
like the fans are usually clueless about
what is next
but so are the actors like there's no
way that i could have known any of the
things that were going to happen in
season four from the very beginning
yeah and i mean from a fan's perspective
too like it was a sigh of relief to see
you appear in season four it's exciting
you had such an explosive entrance in
season three so from an acting
standpoint though
in season three whatever backstory you
maybe gave susie in your head the
character and now we see season four she
has all these siblings a strict father
was it kind of similar to what you kind
of imagined would be like her lifestyle
i thought that she would definitely have
a lot of siblings just because i i was
thinking a lot about like the 80s mormon
culture and everything and i was like
there's there she lives right in salt
lake she's got to have
a nice like
you know really ultra talented family if
she's like singing and doing science and
like going to summer camp for like
becoming a female in stem um and then i
saw it and i was like
i love that they played it off in a
comedic way and it was like a huge heist
because i couldn't have
thought of something better to bring in
all of those new characters from a new
location because the thing about season
four i mean spoilers but it's kind of
obvious you're in so many different
places and focusing on so many different
story lines like
bringing new people in with something
memorable and fun and light-hearted is
like
the perfect way to do it in my opinion
so was it also you're talking about all
these storylines coming in this season
too but also that you got to spend time
now and work with the other cast because
you were in a solo appearance last
season so
how was that compared to your experience
with season three
oh it was so fun um mainly i think the
thing that like really was the most fun
for me
was like
all of the improv work that we got to do
especially with eduardo he plays argyle
um all of the scenes that we did he like
completely improved a lot of his stuff
that ended up making the final cut um
and so we would all be playing off of
him and
i think there's like one line that ended
up being in the final cut too that um
is like you're being sarcastic and i go
yeah and that was never scripted that
just kind of happened because finn was
like
there was a long silence and then he was
like i'm gonna say something and then he
said something and i was like it was a
lot of like playing off of each other
which i never got to have in season
three
and even at the beginning of season four
when i'm talking with dustin
you know it was just me and gayton all
along and getting to do a scene with a
bunch of different people
straight from doing a scene with one
person multiple times
like it was definitely shocking and all
of the like fun extra improv that we got
to do was like so memorable
yeah and you mentioned gate and i want
to bring that up because is it a real
challenge to play this powerful love
susie has for dustin but you guys
actually haven't been in the scene
together yet you get this is as long as
relationship is that challenging to kind
of get into that
right right yeah i feel like all the
fans are just waiting for them to meet
in real life
and like you don't see them in real life
because you know they're supposed to
have met like in summer camp but i don't
think that they've seen each other since
then you know in my mind which is which
is wild um but i actually i grew up with
gay in and i grew up just knowing his
family
so
honestly from being like nine-year-olds
playing in the park together in new york
city to like
being like best friends slash like in a
relationship it's like
not the hugest deal and i honestly i i
got a lot of tips and pointers from his
girlfriend lizzy um
just like yeah yeah yeah like and we
were like playing off of each other and
thinking about different funny things
like uh
you know that would be fun to do with
him because
then honestly that um that all like
improv with him was like so much more
fun knowing about like what it is like
to like be in a relationship with him
from his actual girlfriend
yeah that that's great and that's cool
that you put in that effort as an
actress that's actually awesome um and
speaking of just your acting becoming
susie
have you found any of gabriella in susie
or is this a complete transformation for
you
i feel like honestly
there is a lot of susie that is
completely unique uh in terms of like i
have never played a character
that is as religious as susie is and
there's a lot of like science and
mathematical genius that goes into
playing her and i always loved science
and math and
my dad loves computers so honestly it
was more him being like oh like this is
gonna be so fun you get to hack like
it's like
a lot of the people that i was around
were like super excited for me to get to
do this and i it just made me even more
excited
and i think that
one of the things about susie that i
find
in myself is like her versatility and
love for
many different things because obviously
she loves to
work with computers and and
be with her family but she also like
loves to sing and she has this secret
relationship and like people think she's
so
innocent and she's honestly got this
whole
you know wild life going on and i think
that a lot of like that versatility of
like loving so many things and trying to
invest herself in so many different
things
is one of the things that i like to do
too so that that is pretty similar i
would say
yeah and i like how you go into how
complicated the characters really is
with what you're saying and one of the
funniest lines of the season to me was
susie saying after changing dusty's
grade i was racked with the most awful
guilt so that says a lot about susie to
me in a sense too like is it in susie's
head is it always like a war between her
love for dustin but her strict faith
like is she kind of also clashing those
two things
yeah yeah i'd say that generally i'm
also like very like i don't like to
break the rules very often um i always
grew up like
if i did something i knew wasn't right i
would just have to confess like
immediately
yeah actually that's very similar too i
love that
yeah yeah and i think that like having
two totally opposite things going on in
her life for her like absolutely
juxtaposing each other like
is
something that causes her a lot of guilt
and and sometimes just like
a lot of confusion um and she's just
she's just a kid who's trying to deal
with it you know
at the end of the day and i think that
like
having that be a whole like comedic bit
was like
so fun to read and then even more fun to
act out
um because you're like you're acting so
serious and adamant about like wanting
to do the right thing but you know that
it's going to be something that people
laugh at you know right right yeah and
you you do such a good job at it and
it's props to how good you are comedic
acting which is very hard so
it's awesome you can do that and i also
thought it was interesting you shared a
clip that was showing that first scene
we see susie where there's like a blue
screen behind you when she's on the roof
and it seems like there's a fan blowing
wind on you was that hard to act with
how do you act with blue screen before
was that like a different kind of
challenge
yeah i actually had and it was on
stranger things oh wow it's really crazy
because like
any of the exteriors of like
my house
were blue screen
and
so anything outside my window or even
like my glasses lens
like they had like dots and then they
would take out the lens and then like if
you like pretend like there's something
there but like there's going to be
nothing there
like reflect what we end up putting on
your computer
onto your lens it's like such attention
to detail it was like
astonishing um yeah
that's crazy and yeah i would never even
think of that so that's really cool that
must've been wild and also speaking of
just great videos you also share on your
instagram there was this great video of
the crew giving you a nice surprise on
your birthday for season four can you
kind of go a little more detail what
exactly happened there
yeah yeah absolutely so i showed up for
work that day and
it was my birthday and people were like
oh happy birthday but they didn't say
much and i was like we're just trying to
get a lot of work done that makes total
sense
um
and all of the cast was super nice and
they were doing fun stuff all day long
just to make it not seem suspicious that
nobody was doing anything crazy
um and then at the very end of the day i
saw our director nimrod and he's like
the absolute greatest and he's the one
who ended up like figuring out with the
80s like the whole like getting me a
cake and
they had like
outdoor
like games and stuff for people after we
finished shooting
um
and so he pulled noah aside no schnapp
and
he was like whispering and i was like
something is weird i don't think
directors would do that like right in
front of me and so i was like okay
something's up and as soon as i walked
outside everyone was congregated and i
was like oh gosh oh gosh
and then it was like super sweet and
they sang and they got me a cake and it
was this whole fun festive thing
and so i played a few games and then i
like went back in to like
have more takes of me just like typing
at a computer like
very viciously like i was coding and
then they were like okay go play more
games like you're good
i love that yeah it's cool too because
it sounds like it's so much fun filming
season four and
leading off of that then having the big
season four premiere
was that crazy now with everyone knowing
your character when you're at this
premiere like was that surreal having
this like wild fans just shouting your
name and stuff
yeah i mean it was definitely really fun
to get to see the fans because they
actually had some people who were
allowed to go who were fans of the show
um and it was so nice we got to like
take pictures with them and
you know just different selfies and and
fun things and talk to them for like a
little little bit
um but at the other premiere at first
season three nobody was supposed to know
that i really existed or that i was real
and that i wasn't just like a figment of
dustin's imagination
so
i i think that it was very different
from my season three premiere because
most of the people in the cast knew me
but not a lot of the people
other than that knew who i was or why i
was there they just thought i was a
friend of a friend or something
um and then this premiere i got to like
do a lot more in terms of seeing people
and talking to people
um and i think that it was very
refreshing because
it was like no no secrets had to be kept
except for what was already in the show
um i didn't have to like have this like
alternate identity where i was not in
the show right
so yeah yeah yeah
relief yeah yes for sure
and
gabrielle before i let you go i have to
ask is that a picture of baby dustin
behind you that's hanging over your head
oh my gosh
i wish that would be really really funny
this is my sister
okay um
yeah no definitely not gay and um
i do have a lot of pictures with gayten
when we were that age okay
yeah yeah i was just making sure you
weren't method actor or anything maybe
your method who knows no
no no no no no not like that not like
that
i love that uh gabrielle thank you so
much for joining me everybody obviously
keep watching stranger things volume one
of season four and volume two is coming
out july first i cannot wait and just
keep watching gabriel crush it here at
susie gabrielle thank you so much for
joining me today and i hope to talk to
you in the future
of course thank you for having me